i am doing a debate tomorrow with a
party who thinks that children aren't
mature enough to decide their gender and
everyone should be on blockers
help oh my god that i actually have not
heard something true twisted
into that conclusion before someone who
thinks that children aren't mature
enough to decide their gender
they're exploring identity that's what
children do and
therefore everyone should be on blockers
so a blockers is about
sex is about transform
trying to transform all the parts of sex
that you can without
actually getting to anything fundamental
because you can't
so wait wait wait this person thinks
that children should be
put on blockers so this is going to be
puberty blockers it's going to be crazy
sexy
it's not cross-sex hormones it's actual
blockers
so i mean look there's only there's only
one argument against this and that is
who the hell do you think you are
yeah who the hell do you think you are
that you know
so much about this stuff that you are in
a position to disrupt
normal development you know what this
reminds me of this reminds me of
in researching the book i came across a
movement
in the early 20th century among american
medical doctors
who had um they were worried about the
appendix and it's this vestigial organ
and couldn't figure out what it was good
for and um
we're not going to tell that whole story
now but it turns out it's actually good
for a lot of things and it depends on on
your environmental context
uh but they then went i dare say it's
like 8 or 20 steps further and they
decided that
not only were they certain that the
appendix was not good for anything but
the large intestine
was actually useless and they were
advocating for just getting rid of it
because
it's clearly not doing anyone any good
this this is
that kind of batshit naivete that's even
worse
it's even worse i mean you know it's
kids it's development like
yeah they're gonna destroy people
they're going to destroy people this is
just completely unacceptable
and uh i mean just even even at the
point that somebody
formulates such an argument says it out
loud and doesn't immediately understand
that what they've said is insane
um we got a serious problem there's
something
there's something in this and i ran into
this with um
sort of like really dim
faculty who had been semi-trained
in humanities or social sciences but not
like the legit humanities and social
sciences these are just
dim post-modern critical theory
humanities social science types
who seem to really believe that
um everything about the universe was
created at the point that humans started
talking about that thing
like that's actually the the
foundational premise of a lot of this
stuff
know you'd be talking like well of
course darwin darwinism is racist
no it's not well these people who were
talking about it were racist
like just because the thing has been
abused by idiots and racists doesn't
make it
idiotic or racist and you know
children are interested
in figuring out who they are and in
being transgressive
and in exploring limnality and in
in doing all of the exploration that is
what children are about that's why we
have the longest developmental periods
relative to our lifetime on the planet
you should therefore conclude exactly
the opposite yeah
you don't mess with their development
with giving them exogenous
drugs you don't do it unless it is
absolutely a hundred percent required
by for some reason that is distinct to
them
for which nothing else has worked and
everything else that should be tried
first
includes everything from diet to
exercise to light regime
to family situation all of these things
you don't start with drugs and
hopefully you never you don't end with
drugs and accept the rarest cases
that's insane yeah that's that's insane